you're watching the daily climate show
on sky news coming up on today's
programme as demand for lithium source a
warning that the minerals needed to fill
our net zero transition are in short
supply
the third named storm in a week batters
the uk but has climate change had any
part to play
and wildfires in argentina burned
through one of the world's largest
freshwater wetlands
[Music]
hello and welcome to the uk's only daily
climate news show where we track the
changes happening in our world right now
and challenge those coming up with the
solutions and we start with a warning
that the transition to net zero could be
compromised by the ability of the mining
industry to keep up with the demand for
minerals needed to fuel battery power
it's accepted that moving to electric
vehicles is a key part of the plan to
reduce carbon emissions but this
requires using minerals like lithium-ion
which have their own environmental
consequences
now by
2035 is expected that more than half of
new passenger vehicles sold worldwide
will be electric but scientists are
already facing problems sourcing some of
the metals needed for ev batteries in
particular lithium
and although the amount needed varies
depending on the car and battery type of
course a single car lithium ion pack
contains approximately eight kilograms
of lithium
now even though the cost of lithium had
been going down it's now on the rise as
mining companies struggle to keep up
with demand
now towards the end of
2021 lithium prices started to soar and
so far the price has continued to rise
this year
and there are serious concerns about the
lithium extraction process now at the
moment there are two main processes the
first one involves building a mine
extracting the clay or all and
separating the metal but it's considered
a really carbon intensive method
now the second one is a method used
across latin america which involves over
two million liters of water to produce
one ton of lithium
our climate change correspondence hannah
thomas peter has spoken to the chief
executive of the international council
of metals and mineral mining and he's
issued a stark warning that the global
net zero transition will be in jeopardy
if the world cannot close the large gap
between the supply and demand for the
material critical to the green
revolution
there is no net zero transition without
the metals and minerals needed to power
it absolutely so if we don't succeed in
meeting the world's demand for metals
through primary production through
recycling and through reminding existing
waste then i think it is in jeopardy
because the new technologies are so
metals intensive again i'll give an
example a traditional car that you might
drive takes about
you know 10 kilograms 15 kilograms of
copper when we all switch to driving
electric vehicles that jumps by five
times so each car then uses five times
as much copper as what we use today so
in the global copper market at the
moment about four percent of copper
demand is made up from the vehicle
market by 2030 that's going to be 12
so just our demand for electric vehicles
is going to drive the demand for copper
to such an extent and it's really hard
to build a car without copper so if we
yes if we don't fix this demand supply
gaps in
for metals and minerals then
it's very hard to imagine a net zero
transition
i'm thinking about the price of lithium
one analyst said that it was rising at
an absurd rate and that it constituted
kind of panic buying prices
what is going on there and what can be
done to mitigate the associated risks so
when it comes to lithium the reason
prices have risen is because we can see
a quite large mismatch between demand
and supply so we currently produce about
400 000 tons of lithium by 2030 that's
likely to jump to around 2 million tons
and so to close that gap will mean
lithium supply having to come on stream
really really quickly at rates we've
never had to grow this before now
generally you can get lithium from two
different sources you can get lithium
from hard rocks like we mine in
australia and that's about two thirds of
the global lithium supply or you can get
it from brines like we have in latin
america that's about a third of supply
now the challenge here is
one process is really carbon intensive
the other process is really water
intensive so to extract lithium from
hard rock to get one tonne of lithium
generates about 15 tonnes of co2 as we
do so and then when it comes to the
brines to generate one tonne of lithium
takes about two million liters of water
to produce one tonne of lithium just to
put that in context that's about the
amount of water that a person would use
in the uk in 36 years and so what are we
going to do well what we're going to do
here the industry has been innovating so
in addition to these two primary sources
of lithium supply today we're also
exploring ways to extract lithium from
geothermal brines as well as from clay
deposits that will allow us to overcome
some of these challenges that are
holding us back
and our climate correspondent hannah
thomas peter joins me now and hannah
what can be done then to address the
amount of these minerals that we need
for the batteries for electric power
well this is a central issue as you
heard there without the right materials
to power the green revolution there is
no transition to net zero carbon
emissions
by 2050. i mean you heard there the
explanation the mining industry the
extraction industry are developing new
technologies to try and re-mine existing
deposits for example new technologies to
try and extract copper and lithium and
other metals from different sorts of
deposits but none of those are yet being
used at scale and so the blunt truth is
that we have to get more copper lithium
and other metals out of the ground new
mines have to be developed now that gets
really complicated because that will
take a lot of time it will take a huge
amount of money and there are
complicated layers over the top of the
practical issues around extraction there
are local political issues you know
local opposition to mines in serbia
portugal and even america which has
traditionally been very pro-mining have
halted or slowed
entire projects then you've got the new
shape of
world geopolitics which is being remade
around access to these critical
materials china has becoming a is
becoming a renewable superpower securing
access to lithium mines across the world
there is a concern about countries
starting to stockpile lithium and copper
in order to secure their own supply
chains
there are concerns about new governments
being elected in places like chile the
world's largest copper producer
that countries just elected a very hard
left leader which is who is looking at
nationalizing or punitively taxing
extraction industries to try and gain
maximum value from that country's
natural resources but that creates an
uncertain business environment where
will all that investment go will it stay
in chile and then of course on top of
all of those layers you've got the
rightly rising environmental and social
standards for extraction what are all
these big minds going to do about the
incredibly carbon
and sometimes water intensive process
for extracting these critical
metals and minerals and how are they
going to guarantee that human rights
aren't violated and that local
communities and countries get their fair
set fair share of natural resources of
natural resources that are needed
globally for this huge transition
so these big companies that haven't
engendered an awful lot of trust because
of historical issues with the
environmental and social harm done with
extraction they've got a lot of
questions to answer and so do
governments
if the transition to net zero carbon
emissions within the coming decades is
going to be a successful one
absolutely hannah thank you
now storm franklin the third named storm
to hit the uk in a week has seen rivers
bursting their banks properties
evacuated and tens of thousands of homes
left without power now while climate
scientists say that extreme weather
events cannot be linked directly to the
climate crisis many believe that the
impact of storms like these is
increasing as a global temperatures rise
our correspondence insane rasheed has
this update
so let's try and give you a sense of
what the situation is like here in
manchester we've seen severe flooding
over the last 24 hours
or so particularly sunday evening into
early monday morning this is a playing
field behind as you can see completely
flooded that's as a result of the mersey
river bursting its banks that recorded
some of the highest levels of flooding
ever on record now we know there were
two severe flood warnings issued by the
environment agency on sunday evening
that meant that there was a danger to
life and 70 homes in the area were
evacuated as a result those people are
now back in their homes and the water
levels have reduced significantly on
monday morning those severe warnings
were removed by the environment agency
if you can have a look here the river's
still flowing incredibly quickly and
there's a lot of debris caught up
by the bridge as well we know a lot of
trees have been knocked over because of
the severe winds that we've been having
as well so this is still a concern for
the environment agency but why is all
this happening in particular flooding
there's still a lot of questions around
that and scientists never really draw an
immediate and direct connection between
the severe weather that we've been
having and climate change but they are
becoming increasingly confident that
climate change is absolutely responsible
for this sort of weather particularly
flooding and this globally
as well there is a general pattern of
increasingly frequent increasingly
severe weather events why is that well
the earth is warming a rise in sea
levels and we're potentially seeing more
rainfall than ever before in a short
period of time which causes this sort of
flooding so areas like this
might now need to put more focus on
adapting to these changes to protect
themselves in the future and there will
be a big question about where local
authorities spend their money to protect
livelihoods in these sorts of areas
because of climate change causing this
severe sort of weather
rasheed there without updates now moving
on to some of the day's other climate
news now organizations are warning that
the government's leveling up plans will
fail unless they include access to
nature now new research finds that 85
percent of people in nature deprived
areas say that more natural spaces would
improve their quality of life
the nature for everyone campaign is
calling for a legal right to nature to
be a key part of the government's
leveling up reforms
those disparities have been there for a
long time and they deepen other
inequality in our society that leads to
major health and employment
opportunities it leads to real changes
in life chances so it might feel like
something extra in life but actually
leveling up access to nature is a really
big part of creating equality of
opportunity and life chances
advise in northeastern argentina have
burned through more than 800 hectares
scarring farmlands and killing protected
animals and plants in an important
wetland area
in iberia national park one of the
world's largest freshwater wetlands the
fires have affected diverse wildlife
which includes threatened animals such
as marsh deer alligators and more than
380 species of birds
there's growing demand for ethically
sourced and sustainable products that's
according to a new report
the fair trade foundation says sales
increased by 14
in 2020.
the foundation says there were
particular demands for fur trade cocoa
bananas wine gold and cosmetics
egypt and the us have launched a joint
working group to prepare for the cop 27
climate change summit in sham sheikh in
november
the u.s climate envoys visit to egypt
comes 100 days after the glasgow climate
pact at cop26 when governments committed
to revisit their emissions goals in 2022
and ramp up finance to help poorer
countries cope with the impact of
climate change
we meet this morning here in egypt well
aware
of other tensions in the world
understanding that there are
lives and principles at stake
in what is happening with respect to
ukraine today but that does not change
the reality of what is happening every
day
with respect to our climate
that is a national international
security threat to all of us
so we must continue to work every day
please stay with our speakers coming up
we'll be discussing how far we have or
have not come since cop 26 which took
place in glasgow with climate scientists
dr ella gilbert and senior lecturer in
climate law at edinburgh university in
navraj singh gali there they are see you
after the short break
hello and welcome back to the daily
climate show here on sky news and we're
getting straight to discussing the
climate issues of the day with climate
and polar scientists dr ella gilbert and
senior lecturer in climate law at
edinburgh university navraj singh gali
and there they are we'll be getting to
them in just a few minutes but first
though in the last week tens of
thousands of homes have been left
without power the transport network has
faced major disruption and dozens of
homes have been evacuated as they have
been stormed which of course have been
lashing the uk
storms dudley storm eunice and of course
storm franklin well there they are now
let me just throw the first question
then to you then ella now while we can't
attribute of course every particular
storm to climate change what role do you
think though that they play in terms of
their frequency and intensity
well there's actually fairly limited
evidence that climate change is making
storms like dudley eunice or franklin
more intense or more frequent what we do
know though is that climate change is
increasing the severity of the impacts
that are associated with those storms so
for example we see more intense rainfall
and snowfall in some cases as the
climate warms and also because we've got
rising sea levels it means that we get
more intense storm surges that can reach
further up the coast it means that if we
do get those intensive rainfall periods
then you can get more inland flooding as
rivers burst their banks and things like
this and the the effects of these storms
can be more keenly felt and navraj
what's your view on this then the
current situation that we're facing
we're seeing you know three storms in a
matter of a week
yeah i mean it's uh i think as was just
said i mean there are some physical
impacts such as sea level rise or ocean
acidification which can be attributed to
climatic climate change with uh with
anthropogenic climate change with a high
degree of confidence um but the sorts of
events we're seeing are it's much harder
to link the um any given emission to any
particular outcome
but there's a lot of work being done to
try and connect those dots um but i
think we're clearly quite not quite
there yet
and in terms of not being there quite
yet actually this actually looks as our
whole infrastructure and i'll come to
you there ella is there something that
we need to be doing to prepare for
storms like these because every time it
happens we're seeing the problems that
people are facing with the lack of power
and it goes on for ages for days
sometimes
absolutely and my heart really goes out
to anyone who's been really
impacted negatively by these storms i
think we need to increase the amount of
action and work that we're putting into
actually preparing for these sorts of
events because extreme events generally
not just storms but you know flooding
droughts heat waves all of these kinds
of extremes are going to become more
frequent and more intense when they do
occur as the climate warms this problem
isn't going away anywhere anytime soon
and we really need to do everything that
we can not only to mitigate to prevent
the problem becoming even worse but also
to really adapt to the changes that are
already inevitable
and navraj what's the solution here what
do we need to be doing in order to
prepare for storms like these
there's a there's a need for a much
greater policy focus on adaptation i
think ella put it quite nicely when she
talked about the difference between
mitigation and adaptation a lot of
policy and
in this space is really about reducing
our emissions we're now at the stage
where reducing we just can't reduce our
emissions quickly enough we are going to
be living with degree we are living and
will continue to live with a degree of
climate change we need to respond to
that and that is and there's a whole
raft of um actions which need to be
taken part of the pro the problem is
twofold here on the one hand adaptation
tends to be highly localized it's not
something that lo that central
government can do we can readily
undertake
riverbank strengthening or floodplain
protection and so on
the the flip side to that is that local
governments in this country and in most
other jurisdictions are not as not as
well funded or coordinated
as central government so there's both a
problem uh or a capacity problem and a
technical problem there
all right thank you both very much for
the moment
but now it's a hundred days would you
believe it time moved so quickly since
the nation's promise to take serious
steps to try to stop global temperatures
rising by more than 1.5 degrees there
were a lot of pledges that were made at
cop26 all eyes were here we're on the uk
there seems to be a real lack of
momentum there doesn't there we're not
seeing much of the evidence of those
pledges that were made actually coming
to fruition and here on the daily
climate show we actually spoke to the
president of palau just a couple of
weeks ago and he told us here that they
are basically their existence is
threatened daily and one of the key
quotes that's coming out today comes
from john kerry who is of course a u.s
climate home boy and i'll just read that
to you he says tackling climate change
is a serious threat that requires
accelerated action even as industrial
action international action that is is
focused on russia and ukraine what do
you think is gone on
why are we at this stage where not much
has been done
i think is as usual it's a political
will problem i mean we've known what we
need to do to tackle climate change for
decades and i think this is just another
kind of symptom of of that problem um as
john kerry says we need to
really start to take action in a
meaningful way despite the distractions
that are going on across the world stage
whether that's the ukraine russia crisis
whether that's closer to home at the
cost of living crisis or even partygate
dare i mention it i think all of these
things are always going to be continuing
to happen in the background but climate
change is something that isn't going
away we can't just choose to ignore it
we have to do everything that we can and
that means really
actually taking action on those pledges
that we've made whether that's halting
deforestation or starting to move really
dramatically away from fossil fuels and
rather than you know investing in in new
oil fields or new shale gas for example
now rogers ella was just saying the
political will problem do you agree with
that
yes and no i mean i think it's clearly
the case that that we're not seeing the
uh massive transformational changes that
uh the science requires to avoid one and
a half degrees warming what we are
seeing though is a huge amount of very
granular details patient work taking
place
across a wide range of sectors so
yesterday united states
changed its licensing system for new gas
fossil gas pipelines that's a really big
step there's ongoing work about the
support of international um uh finance
public finance for uh fossil fuels and
uh coal in particular uh this is stuff
which was you know completely off the
agenda even as recently as two or three
years ago it's now happening or in some
cases already happened
it's all you know it's relatively low
salience it's not picked up um but it is
happening is it happening fast enough no
um could we have imagined that even this
would be happening recently not at all
so i'm i'm i'm very much a glass half
full on this issue
not all issues but this one
no rose thank you very much and this
leads me on to my next point there um
ella because part of the criticism that
came out of the cop 26 summits was that
there were just too many words and not
enough action as i said
so what should we be doing then to
monitor those pledges that those
governments made how do we monitor those
changes that they actually make
i think that's a really challenging
issue and it's something that is or has
at least been kind of lacking in the
historical uh trajectory just because
there isn't some kind of centralized
body necessarily that has the authority
to really hold nations to account and i
think in
the sense that we can all hold our
leaders to account
the public can play a really important
role um and we can continue to demand
that our leaders and everyone in power
whether that's from government to
business to
all the other kind of organizations
across society are making those sorts of
changes that we want to want to see to
create the society that we want to see
well climate and polar scientists dr
ella gilbert and senior lecturer in
climate law at edinburgh university
navrag singh gali grateful for your time
thank you
thank you
well do you join us tomorrow because
we'll be joined by hosts of climate
curious podcast nariyam pesha and the
executive director of energy and climate
policy think tank climate imperative
bruce niles
and that is it from me thank you very
much indeed for your company i hope you
can join me again tomorrow see you then
[Music]
you